GRIFF: DAVID SPUNT, LIVE FOR US
IN THE WHITE HOUSE, DAVID, THANK
YOU.
JACQUI.
>> GOVERNMENT SHOULD NOT REQUIRE
ANY TEXAN TO SHOW PROOF OF
VACCINATION AND REVEAL PRIVATE
HEALTH INFORMATION JUST TO GO
ABOUT THEIR DAILY LIVES.
>> BOTTOM LINE IS WE ARE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO IMPLEMENT THE LAW
WHICH THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES HAS THE ABILITY,
THE AUTHORITY, THE LEGAL
AUTHORITY TO DO.
JACQUI: TEXAS GOVERNOR GREG
ABBOTT AND JEN PSAKI SPARRING
OVER THE LEGALITY OVER THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION’S VACCINE MANDATE
AS THE FIGHT BETWEEN WHITE HOUSE
AND REPUBLICAN GOVERNORS HEATS
UP.
JOINING US NOW FOR REACTION
URBAN REFORM PRESIDENT AND
MEMBER OF THE TEXAS ADVISORY
COMMITTEE OF THE U.S. COMMISSION
ON CIVIL RIGHTS CHARLES BLANE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING WITH
US.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME, JACQUI.
JACQUI: WALK US THROUGH,
CHARLES, WHAT’S YOUR TAKE ON
WHERE THINGS STAND RIGHT NOW.
>> APPLAUD THE GOVERNOR FOR
DOING WHAT HE DID.
I THINK ONE OF THE BIG THINGS
THAT HAS BEEN A PART OF THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT VACCINE AND
VACCINE MANDATES IS THAT ONE OF
THE BIG GROUPS THAT HAVE BEEN
RELUCTANT TO GET THEM, THEY LOOK
LIKE ME.
SO WE ARE TALKING ABOUT BLACK
AND HISPANIC FOLKS, LARGELY
FOLKS WHO ARE WAGE WORKERS WHO
ARE WORKING PUBLIC FACING JOBS
SO THEY ARE REALLY GOING TO FEEL
THE CRUNCH OF A VACCINE MANDATE.
AND SO WITH THE GOVERNOR
STEPPING IN, IT’S ENSURING THAT
THEY DON’T HAVE TO MAKE THE
DECISION OF THEIR LIVELIHOOD AND
CONTINUING TO PUT FOOD ON THE
TABLE VERSUS WHAT THEY FEEL IS
RIGHT FOR THEIR PERSONAL HEALTH.
SO I APPLAUD THE DECISION AND I
THINK HE NEEDS TO HOLD STEADY ON
IT.
JACQUI: IN YOUR VIEW WHAT WOULD
BE THE BETTER ROLE OF THE
GOVERNMENT THEN TO TRY TONE
COURAGE VACCINE HESITANT
POPULATIONS TO GET VACCINATED?
>> WELL, I THINK, YOU KNOW,
LOCALLY HERE IN HARRIS COUNTY IN
HOUSTON WE HAVE SEEN OUR LOCAL
OFFICIALS GETTING OUT THERE AND
GOING TO COMMUNITY EVENTS,
HOLDING VACCINATION EVENTS,
REALLY SHOWING THAT THEY ARE
GETTING IT THEMSELVES AND THAT
IT’S SAFE AND EFFECTIVE WAY OF
COMBATING THE VIRUS BUT THE
MANDATE DOESN’T SEEM TO BE THE
ANSWER.
ESPECIALLY BLACK AND HISPANIC
FOLKS ARE HESITANT OF GOVERNMENT
AND THEY HAVE A DEEP MISTRUST OF
GOVERNMENT, SO MANDATING
SOMETHING FROM GOVERNMENT IS NOT
GOING TO FLY WITH THEM.
AND SO I REALLY THINK THAT JUST
GETTING OUT THERE AND
COMMUNICATING CONTINUING TO
COMMUNICATE THE MESSAGE OF THE
NEED FOR VACCINES AND THE NEED
FOR ENSURE THAT THE POPULATION
IS SAFE IS GOING TO BE WITH THE
ANSWER IS.
I DON’T THINK MANDATES ARE IT.
JACQUI: IN YOUR VIEW THE MANDATE
DOES THE OPPOSITE, IT MAKES THEM
FOR HESITANT?
CHARLES: OH, WITHOUT A DOUBT.
IT MAKES THEM MORE HESITANT AND
I THINK IT MAKES THEM QUESTION
THE MOTIVES OF GOVERNMENT SIMPLY
BECAUSE NOW YOU’RE SAYING THAT
THEY HAVE TO MAKE THE DECISION
BETWEEN THEIR LIVELIHOOD AND
WHAT THEY CHOOSE FOR THEIR
PERSONAL HEALTH.
I DEFINITELY THINK IT DOES THE
COMPLETE OPPOSITE AND THERE WERE
-- THERE WAS CONVERSATION
SHORTLY AFTER HANDING OUT OF THE
MANDATE THAT BLACK VOTERS WHO
SUPPORTED PREVIOUSLY WERE A
LITTLE MORE QUESTIONING WHAT HE
WAS DOING AND THEY WERE MORE
RELUCTANT TO SUPPORT HIM GOING
FORWARD AND THAT’S A
LONG-STANDING THING IF HE
CONTINUES TO SHOVE THIS DOWN A
POPULATION’S THROAT THAT HAS A
DEEP MISTRUST OF GOVERNMENT.
JACQUI: THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION
ALSO HAS BEEN CAREFUL TO TRY TO
FIND WAYS WHERE THEY DO HAVE
LEGAL GROUND TO DO THAT IN TERMS
OF, YOU KNOW, ENCOURAGING
BUSINESSES TO MAKE THESE
MANDATES WHERE THEY CANNOT REACH
OVER IN THEIR FEDERAL CAPACITY.
DO YOU THINK THAT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE IF IT’S COMING FROM,
YOU KNOW, YOUR EMPLOYER AT THE
URGING OF THE GOVERNMENT VERSUS,
YOU KNOW, SOME SORT OF A MANDATE
THAT’S ENACTED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF LABOR FOR CERTAIN EMPLOYERS,
MORE THAN 100 WORKERS, DO YOU
THINK THAT THAT MAKES A
DIFFERENCE IF IT’S COMING FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE VERSUS THE
PERSON YOU WORK FOR?
>> CHARLES: I DON’T THINK IT
MAKES A DIFFERENCE FOR THE
AVERAGE PERSON BECAUSE AT THE
END OF THE DAY, THEY THEN HAVE
TO MAKE THE DECISION BETWEEN
WHAT THEY’RE CHOOSING FOR
PERSONAL HEALTH CARE AND PUT
FOOD ON THE TABLE AND BRING
PAYCHECK EVERY TWO WEEKS OR THE
END OF THE MONTH.
I DON’T THINK IT MAKES MUCH OF A
DIFFERENCE AND I THINK PEOPLE
RECOGNIZE THAT THE FORCE OF THIS
IS STILL COMING FROM GOVERNMENT.
THAT WHETHER OR NOT THEIR
EMPLOYERS CHOOSE TO ADHERE TO A
MANDATE OR VIOLATE IT THEMSELVES
AND PUT THEMSELVES AT RISK, THAT
FORCE, THAT STRONG ARM OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS STILL
COMING DOWN AND SO YOU KNOW
THAT’S WHY, AGAIN, I APPLAUD
GOVERNOR ABBOTT FOR WHAT HE DID
AND I’M APPLAUDING OUR TEXAS
LEGISLATURE FOR CONSIDERING
LEGISLATION TO CODIFY WHAT HIS
EXECUTIVE ORDER SAYS.